let's let's let's jump over to this next
story real quick and i'm gonna start
with a meme oh yeah let's do it the meme
is um there's an npc guy saying who
radicalized you and then the chad gamer
guy says no one i'm just a normal person
from 10 years ago the reason i start
with this for this segment is that i
posted this because it's funny and then
all the progressives are like you're
showing your true colors we have 10
years of progress the people in the
1950s said the same thing about
interracial marriage and then i was like
and you know what i'm saying the same
thing about
hhs secretary becerra argues transgender
surgeries for minors should be aided by
the government yeah i'm i'm the kind of
guy who's going to be like we should
expand civil rights for people and leave
kids alone and you're telling me it's
progress that the government should be
funding surgeries for minor sex changes
yeah okay well dude please i'm okay with
saying no follow the roman empire notice
that time can pass and you can regress
yeah exactly well this is what i want to
point out i don't know how to explain
this to people but let me try to put it
succinctly
the fact that people in the past at some
point opposed a good thing that ended up
happening does not mean that opposing
change is a bad thing in all instances
that is the dumbest possible argument
you can make for your prisoner oh you're
against things changing well people were
against civil rights gotcha people were
also in favor of eugenics
the progressives
not just people the progressive movement
the left they still are yep but now it
is not socially acceptable so when i say
i'm about a i'm not a humble normal
person from 2012 and they say ha that
means you're conservative uh does that
mean you're still in favor of eugenics
does that mean if you're not you're a
conservative any anyone on the left who
opposes eugenics must be a conservative
along with every other person on the
right huh what they are saying is you
need to mindlessly accept every every
single social change that is pushed on
you by everyone above you and if you
don't do so you are far right that is
their entire argument be a sheep go with
the crowd do what you're told if you
stand up against the modern orthodoxy
which is going to be different five
years from now then you are worthy of
contempt you should be excluded from
public life you're not truly a human
being you don't have rights we're not
going to listen to you speak you are a
far-right psychopathic bigot that's part
of why i don't like calling people
leftists because then they just turn it
around and start yelling right right
right they can tell me i'm on the right
that doesn't bother me
they're the ones who do it and created
it but they it's all this identity crap
like
for real we just got to use common sense
i think but then even that that term
common sense gets abused it's funny
because
i i feel like no amount of evidence will
will show you why you're wrong ian about
what well about you you always say this
all the time like we can't say left you
can't say right you compared me to mao
for saying left and right yeah he talked
about writing and then no matter how
many times i tell you like the left
being an umbrella term describes a kind
of person that are authoritarian that
believe fake news
and then no matter how many times we
invite them on the show they react the
exact same way like screaming lunatics
who don't actually want to have their
ideas challenged i think it's and i keep
showing you the evidence of these things
we try to do there's definitely examples
yeah but to generalize is where it
becomes dangerous yeah like at a certain
point you know but you generalize that
unborn children aren't persons
okay okay well i'm debating that's just
you you have a pattern of behavior we've
exhibited exhibited this pattern of
behavior in like nine out of ten times
when we've invited the so-called left
onto this show nine out of ten times
they behave the exact same way they
create nonsense statements try to use
the invite as some kind of own
or try to in some way attack the show
because so it's like what do we do at
this point when i'm like hey you're a
person who's pro-choice and you're very
angry would you like to come on the show
and then they say something ridiculous
like i want to punch you in the face
then you're already playing identity
politics if you're like i'm going to go
after someone that's pro-choice
they have distanced themselves from
people who believe the way that we it's
not us who's putting them in the bubble
and this is i mean there's there's
studies that showed that conservatives
will follow left-leaning people
and the left will not the and they're
able to quantify that because there is a
difference and the people that are more
on the left do not consume different
opinions whereas people on the right do
they're also significantly more likely
to cut someone out of their life for
having different political people
talking about like radical ideologues i
mean those are there are people that are
like well this is this is the difference
between the left or the right okay so
left-wing people will go you don't agree
with every single part of my niche
left-wing ideological like my ideology
that i discovered online two weeks ago
therefore you're anti-human and i can
never talk to you again and then people
on the right are like someone told me
that they're okay with infanticide
should i still be friends with them let
me show you this from ground.news it's
called blindspotter i pulled up myself
56 of the news tim kest interacts with
on twitter lean's left 20 to center 24
is right leaning
michael malus fairly balanced if you
look at michael mouse's profile you can
see that it's about 45 left leaning
maybe about 20 to 25 percent centrist
and then 20 right jack posobic a
conservative gets most of his news
two-thirds from conservative sources
yeah 60 center vosh has no
uh right-wing sources
so why is it that
i who have
rather left-leaning policy positions i'm
considered on the right because i
consume news across the board even
though i do kind of consume most news
from the left vosh gets none of his news
from the right at all because they're
creating that they're creating the tribe
they're the ones doing this they're
putting the boxes if i'm on the left
then anyone to the right of me is on the
right you got to understand that
okay so it's all relative well so here's
the thing i wouldn't argue that it's all
relative but you're right that there's
an element of subjectivity that comes in
there we see a lot of left-wing people
who will say things like
oh
our political leaders on the left are
actually right-wing by european
standards but even that isn't completely
honest because the stance that most of
them have on abortion is far far left
compared to anything that's enshrined
legally in europe but
we need to strive for some objective
standard and say like okay if if you
support like you know
perverting
children if you support like forcing
perversions onto children and killing
unborn children
and
you know even other things that aren't
so
necessarily intrinsically
bad in that way like just left-wing
economic policy some of those are
horrible some of those there's a
discussion to have like you are on the
left but they will try to argue that
person's actually a moderate because
from my stance they're on law it's like
well you actually have to look at the
political structure songs sort that out
assume what they who even they are i
don't even know what that means that
they wouldn't that they so
i'll explain it to you so i've actually
um over the past four or five years
repeatedly referenced these um
tribal uh um
data maps
showing the left and the right they
completely exist if you look at
twitter's data maps i've done extensive
reporting on the different tribal spaces
the digital they call them digital
countries or digital national nations
you have like the progressives then you
have the staunch democrats you have the
the conservatives then you have the
republicans there's like even a
difference then you have like marketing
which is on the border of progressive
it's really weird twitter marketing
brands border the democrat voter i can
actually i've actually done i i've done
so many segments talking about all of
these things now i think for you ian you
need to look at those data maps and see
they exist there is a there it's the
picture i drew of the two you know
two umbrellas pushing up against each
other where you have the right sphere of
influence and the left sphere of
influence here's blind spotter again
take a look at luke we are change our
good friend luke kowski his news is
perfectly split between conservative
left and
center pretty balanced
sour patch lids baron balance most of
her news from liberal left-wing sources
look look me up
sheamus
that's a crown on my head by the way in
crossland is gets almost none of his
news from the right that's interesting
tell me where i get most of my news i'm
in the middle because that is what it's
all about the left and the right
combined form one large center i think
that's actually very interesting ian
because most of the people i'm looking
at on this don't really have a wide
spread in the middle and you seem to
have a very wide spread in the middle
that was interesting yeah yeah i don't
know who's deciding whether oh that's
not shame so that is not me sheamus
underscore cog that's hilarious not
underscore sheamus underscore coughlin
yeah other shameless underscores
68 left look at this this this far right
right wing conservative bigot mostly
interacts with left-wing news sources
because we know what they think but
you're right it could just be me make
making fun of
i mean obviously any good warrior wants
to understand what their enemy thinks
and if this is really a social war or a
culture where you've got to go pull from
all sources and that doesn't mean you're
on the left if i go no hang out with a
bunch of people that want to kill babies
and transgender their six-year-olds it
doesn't mean that i'm a leftist and if
you put me in a box if you say that if i
hear you say that out loud that i'm a
leftist it's gonna mess with my mind
isn't it hilarious though that everyone
instantly knows that
murdering babies and transgendering
children is like the left how do you
like how much more do you have to do to
convince people that a group is evil
liberal radicalism can become a
dangerous ideology and the liberal
radicals in the french revolution sat on
the left side of the aisle so that term
gets applied to them but it doesn't mean
that people are in some box somewhere
this is you've even acknowledged this
multiple times they're meaningless
phrases they just kind of like
a source of some sort of tribe but
there's so many in like
miniature intricate tribes within tribes
that to
coagulate them for to get a point across
feels destructive i feel like you you
know take a look at how we classify
animals
right
do you know how we classify animals yeah
like phenotype genotype stuff like
chordata or whatever i'm not i'm not at
a biology
yeah i think you under you don't
understand the the the the concept of a
parent tree
right
well yeah i understand that concept okay
so when we say the left we're talking
about a parent yeah that's spherical
you're talking about like a cultural
idea not not like a not like an animal
species that's understanding science
we're not being scientific when we say
left and right this is just a cultural
idea kind of thing it refers to tribe
that's why the left calls me right wing
because i'm not in their tribe and the
right calls you left wing because it's
all relative it's not because the right
knows the political arguments and so
they look at me as my political
arguments not which tribe we're in so
the way i've described it is at some
point we had this american sphere of
influence which was had a left and a
right that mostly agreed on american
values and a constitutional republic at
some point a multicultural democracy
emerged to our left with crazy ideas
2012 and they think everyone in the
original sphere of influence is right
wing
in that sphere of influence the right
and the left still call each other right
and left that's very dangerous too
because they're tribal signifiers tribes
is a very dangerous way to go but that's
that's the reality it exists it's human
nature tribalism is human nature yeah
and using those words left and right
like fortify that nature that dangerous
nature of truth just a way to explain an
idea but it is uh it is a way to do it i
just don't think it's a it's an
effective way and as a journalist it's
not it's not an accurate way to portray
like reality
no it is i i want nothing to do with
them but who are them what is them the
left what
my child about sex in third grade that's
who i want so
let's let's talk about it very very
simply
when i come out and say
kids should not be getting sex change
surgery
that is overtly supported by prominent
left-wing individuals not all of them
however
the other left-wing individuals who
aren't advocating for it call me a
transphobe bigot or a liar for calling
it out yep when i say joe biden did
elicit dealings in ukraine and that's a
fact there are people who don't care
that he did like that he did or will
will just tell me i'm a liar but every
person on that side will say
well i don't know if that's true but you
must be right-wing then yeah exactly if
it goes against their tribe you're the
other so when we talk about the left we
talk about
a collection of policies and ideas that
are not intrinsic among every person on
the left but they all defend it
progressives hate neolibs neolibs hate
progressives these are massive
generalizations all of them
dude
all of them hate all of them all it's
like come on dude you're a journalist
that's not a way to get specific about
things ian
just because i make a general point that
is true does not mean i said every
single progressive hates everything just
said it you said they all hate them and
they all hate them progressives hate
neoliberals that's a generalization it's
a fact i am progressive as hell man i
don't say people it is a fact that if
you go into which i don't think you
understand nuance is the problem if you
go into a room full of progressives and
say how many of you like neolibs they'll
go boo
boo and one person might be like i don't
they're not that bad what about this we
split this round boys and girls you
think we're really going to get along if
that's how we think about things in here
i don't yeah i think
nancy pelosi does not like aoc
aoc does not like nancy pelosi they both
routinely go at each other and rag on
each other and then they vote together
they're catty man it's not it's not i
don't care about the political party
that's irrelevant
that's a generalization about women and
that is a catty thing for people to do
you're knowing the point answer the
argument
they both don't like each other they
both publicly express disdain for each
other they vote together against their
their their their collective enemies
that's the problem of politics we
quantify these by saying there are two
parent tribes that are opposed to each
other the left and the right
libertarians do not get along with
conservatives on a lot of issues
conservatives don't get along with
libertarians a lot of issues they don't
hate each other though but they will
vote together on most issues like the
pro-life issue right now you see dave
smith you see michael malus very much
against the establishment the cathedral
progressives lined up to vote for joe
biden even though they say they hate him
that's why we say they are the left
because there are certain things they
would support even if they don't like
them but they wouldn't support mike
pence mike pence is the other tribe
there's a parent sphere of influence
called a left and a right they're not
absolute there are some overlap but it's
overwhelmingly two different spheres of
influence they they are unified in a way
i
i was not allowed into a mom's group
using my name
because of my right-leaning politics in
a very liberal city
i i get the
i have problems when we people use past
actions to define future like say i
think there was a video you might have
to that is actually the best you gotta
be careful because okay in the past
there was like i think it was black
violence statistics there was a bunch in
the past a lot of like it was like some
random number 20 of all these crimes
were committed by this kind of person
this black people so therefore
black people are 20 percent or five
times more likely to do this than white
people but you're assuming the future
based on what they did in the past so
but they were just taking it out of
context because it was black on black
crime ian also i think projecting but i
don't think this argument works because
you're saying that there have been
unfair generalizations in the past
therefore we should dispense with the
idea of generalizing alternatives i'm
saying if someone made some decisions in
the past it doesn't mean that in the
future they're part of a tribe sure but
like when if there has been a consistent
thread throughout the entire history of
a group such as the left where basically
any time they've come to power they have
oppressed people every time they've
majorly seized power on the extreme left
they've slaughtered people
no i'm not saying that the right hasn't
but when we talk about the left there
are certain threads that we can see
through so they they they are there's
authoritarianism of all like i never
said there was i never said there wasn't
i'm saying when you look at the common
threads on the left it's fair to say
that this is what the left is about
there's a reason we use that term to
label id logs in our country it's not
fair so then you're making his argument
it's not fair to define the left and
right differently there are common
threads are there not common threads on
the left you saying that the common
thread of the left is authoritarianism
and oppression yeah that's a common
thread for humanity okay that's fair but
i think that when you look at left-wing
ideology it breaks down social
structures in a way that you need the
imposition of authoritarian rules with
their specific ideology to shift the
social structure
we saw that in revolutionary france when
the left was incepted when they first
came to be we saw it everywhere that
there was a revolution where the left
took power afterwards we see it in
in germany we see it in chile sure i'm
not no i'm not saying the right doesn't
become authoritarian or violent either
that's not i don't i don't think
authoritarianism is the right way to
define what the tribes are necessarily
today certainly the left is
overwhelmingly authoritarian
i would say that the left's tendency is
always towards becoming authoritarian
and i would also say that when we look
at the common threads they're basically
always against the catholic church
they're always against the family
they're always against the traditional
order basically everywhere you see the
left they're always against the
traditional order yes and the right is
typically for tradition yes but the
issue right now is the right has a
spattering of moderates within it who
have rejected the authoritarianism of
the current left and thus you end up
with a more libertarian right and a more
authoritarian left and part of me
wonders if that's just a consequence of
the fact that one group happens to not
be ascendant so when the right is not in
power it's going to attract more
moderates and people who feel they're
being persecuted by the left yeah i mean
vice versa look at look at gab for
instance uh gab has banned discussion of
porn you know they're they're not okay
with it and so
but they're also not uh
institutionally powerful so no one's
threatened by that
if the law of the land was that certain
political advocacy was not allowed
moderates would start moving away saying
we don't like the idea of the government
imposing its ideas ideology on us
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you